il salue canada que nous voulons partie
plus 1 [ __ ] est au service de vos
convictions de vos valeurs
parce qu'on travaille ensemble on peut
se donner un canada qui nous ressemble
le godet il est encore en devenir le top
job
nous sommes seulement à la fin du mois
de mai et déjà les trois grands partis
fédéraux ont dévoilé leur première
publicité en vue des élections qui
seront déclenchés en principe vers la mi
septembre une campagne déjà bien
commencé donc daniel et ce soir à ottawa
avant soir daniel soir et tasha et
michel sont avec moi en studio
bonsoir alors on est quand même à cinq
mois des élections fédérales ce que
c'est pas un peu tôt pour cette campagne
publicitaire
tasha absolument non c'est ça le
résultat des élections fixe à date fixe
et c'est ce qui arrive c'est comme aux
états unis les parties commencent à
faire campagne ont fait campagne déjà
depuis le budget essentiellement pour
les conservateurs s'étaient je pense la
première sortie de campagne et
maintenant on voit justement les
publicités qui commence à rouler ça va
rouler pendant tout l'été et
potentiellement la campagne bon va
commencer peut-être plutôt qu'on pense
on va voir donc daniel est ce que c'est
pas justement à dire un effet pervers
d'avoir d'avoir des élections à date
fixe est ce que disait un ancien
directeur général des élections monsieur
qui me faisait il y aurait quelqu'un
qu'ils aient à l'ontario il n'y a pas si
longtemps je me souviens plus si c'est
un ministre ou député que avec des
élections à date fixe vous commencez la
campagne électorale non avant les
élections y'a plus rien d'autre qui
compte toute votre attention et porté là
dessus
c'est dommage parce que d'un cas du
fédéral la loi sur le financement des
partis la loi sur les dépenses
électorales
tu sois prudent parce que jusqu'à ce que
se soit déclenché officiellement vous
pouvez dépenser autant d'argent vous
voulez sans que soient comptabilisées
imaginez le parti conservateur qui est
riche comme crésus que des millions et
des millions à dépenser on ne va pas
gêner vous allez voir stephen harper
jusqu'à saturation au cours des
prochaines semaines des prochains mois
ah et si vous êtes de la classe moyenne
on va parler de vous on va vous tapez
landes où vous dorloter sans arrêt
pendant cinq mois
pas certain mois que ça va donner de
très beaux résultats pas servait qu'à la
fin des gens n'auront pas ras-le-bol et
qui voudront passer à autre chose
espérons que non c'est la démocratie qui
est en jeu mais c'est l'une des paires
version wii de 2,2 d'élections à date
fixe ya aucun doute à tuer donc michel
ça va à l'encontre de l'esprit de la loi
électorale et sprimont
oui ça va encore l'esprit c'est vrai que
à l'époque sous l'ancien système quand
les gouvernements décider du moment
déclencher les élections lui savait en
principe entre quand il était pour
déclencher alors ça lui conférait quand
même un certain avantage
mais là ça n'a pas de bon sens et leur
gîte dépenses liées clair que les plus
pauvres ou les moins riches disons
pourront poursuivre il là on parle même
d'une campagne électorale qui pourrait
être allongée de plusieurs semaines mais
cher que de l'image ce sens pour aller
jusqu'à une centaine de jours alors la
magie n'est les parties je pense au npd
les libéraux dans une moindre mesure
mais qui sont obligés de suivre les
conservateurs actuellement et qui flambe
des fortunes vont arriver en campagne
avec chorale avec la caisse à moitié
vide
alors il ya des gens qui ont déjà
réfléchi là dessus par exemple en
grande-bretagne
les dépenses sont comptabilisés dix mois
avant l'élection
alors à ce moment là les gens sont
obligés de faire preuve d'une certaine
sagesse d ici on africa myriam à
certaines périodes tout faire et l'autre
danger et l'autre danger si vous
permettez c'est que ça permet toutes
sortes de groupes d'intervenir dans la
campagne électorale dans la précampagne
électorale
voyez ce matin que des grands syndicats
canadiens uniforme en tête sont en train
de penser à une façon d'intervenir avant
que leurs dépenses soient comptabilisés
avant qu'ils ne puissent pas contribuer
comme ils le veulent à d'intervenir
massivement des syndicats de
fonctionnaires qui sont furieux quand ce
gouvernement à peu des groupes pro ou
contre avortement tous ces gens là
risquent de se manifester de se
retrouver sur la place de dégâts avec
leurs publicités et ça va être une bonne
raison pour le faire écouter la télé
dans les prochaines semaines ces mauvais
les gens vont pas nous écouter
est ce que ce n'est pas la démocratie
dans un sens aussi par ses côtés tous
ces groupes là on se plaint toujours que
les gens n'ont pas une voie pendant
l'élection ils n'ont pas de voix
maintenant la campagne qui n'est pas
officiel a déjà commencé et il ya des
groupes
oui des syndicats mais aussi d'autres
groupes comme working in qui sont les
opposer les syndicats qui vont lutter
dans la classe moyenne c'est la
démocratie du plus riche qu'en mai les
auront pas d'argent pour faire une cape
comme ça qu'ils sont qui sont appuyé la
scène call des groupes qu'ils ont appuyé
aussi par des gens qui travaillent des
gens dans la russe s'est pas
complètement organisé par simplement des
grands d'autres un peu
d'autre part on sait pas exactement
jusqu'à ce que les élections commencent
on sait pas exactement qui financent ces
groupes là parce qu'ils sont pas obligés
de donner la liste de leurs donateurs en
kappa électorale oui mais avant non
alors ça peut être subventionnée par le
parti conservateur pour la partie serait
pas alors nous allons poursuivre dans
leurs publicités les conservateurs vise
uniquement justin trudeau
ils n'ont pas thomas mulcair et pourtant
on l'a vu dans les récents sondages
thomas mulcair
va bien le npd va bien fait des gains
alors en ce moment selon vous qui se
positionne le mieux en fait pour
présenter la meilleure alternative à six
villages mais ça dépend ce que tu veux
c'est justin trudeau promet d'être un
brin d'air frais il est plus jeune
j'étais un changement générationnel au
changement peut-être de perspectives
monsieur mulcair d'ailleurs un programme
qui est le plus différent des
conservateurs idéologiquement alors si
les gens veulent changer de voie changer
de route pour le pays
je pense que c'est monsieur mulcair qui
incarne ce changement politique pas
d'image je suis pas beaucoup il ya pas
beaucoup de différences entre les
conservateurs et les libéraux comme
regarder de près les programmes à partir
du moment où les libéraux de justin
trudeau a fui par exemple le
gouvernement sur le projet doit ses 51
sur l'intervention militaire au moyen
orient et les différences sont très
minces se sont beaucoup plus prononcé
entre le npd sur le scénar par exemple
tu pourrais devenir un enjeu électoral
pour majeur parce que ses intérêts
soient des gens des mineurs sûrement
avec ce qui va se passer la semaine
prochaine
le npd est seul dans son coin disant moi
nous le seul on n'y croit pas on n'en
veut pas on veut l'abolir donc je pense
que thomas mulcair
mais il faut faire attention mais ya
quand même une tendance depuis trois
mois où le npd monte tranquillement où
les libéraux descend tranquillement 6
venard peut se maintient dans sa base
d'eau autour de 30% qui va lui être
fidèle ces gens là de votre chemin pour
d'autres partis
mais regardez ce qui s'est passé
récemment à les gens quand ils veulent
du changement ils veulent du changement
quand ils en ont assez d'un gouvernement
ne se gêne pas pour pour vos l'ex-curé
me relève hans kubrick est né comme ça
on l'a vu au québec malgré des années
charest réélire fait des couilles arts
l'a vu à toronto malgré des années mais
kenty alors y élire une libérale
catherine when the virus qui s'est passé
en alberta les gens n'ont plus la
fidélité qu'ils avaient éteint les
provocations et de savoir est ce que les
gens veulent du changement ou simplement
de la nouveauté vous savez change une
paire de lunettes
c'est pas comme suivre une thérapie qui
vous fait changer complètement de
philosophie de vie prenons juste un
exemple ce trudeau leçon allocations
familiales à les plus progressistes
salle est plus progressive devrait dire
allez pas imposer bon c'est ça la plus
intéressant que ce que monsieur après
propose mais l'alternative de monsieur
monkey lui c'est un système de garderie
nationale alors là on up universel une
commande et une philosophie du rôle de
l'état qui est complètement différente
parce que c'est ça que les canadiens
veulent où ils veulent simplement se
débarrasser
on ne sait pas encore bon alors on l'a
vu dans la dans les publicités je disais
qu'ils visent le site rue gosset
vraiment tentative de définir justin
trudeau on a vu ce que ça a donné avec
avec michael ignatieff avec stéphane
dion qu'est ce que doit faire
justin trudeau pour contrer cette image
que veulent lui donner les concernant
mais il a eu beaucoup de temps de le
contrer les conservateurs disent depuis
longtemps qui n'est pas près qu'il est
trop et qu'il est immature maintenant il
est pas prêt pour gouverner pourrait
être premier ministre
la façon contre et ça c'est de mettre de
la chair sur l'eau c'est d'apporter des
politiques et ça fait très longtemps
libéraux maintenant commence à le faire
mais ils ont gardé de le faire parce
qu'il pensait que le charisme de
monsieur trudeau sa nouveauté
peut-être été assez voulait pas jouer
les cartes avant l'élection mais la
campagne est déjà déclenché alors
maintenant il doit se dépêcher et
montrer du sérieux s'ils veulent contrer
justement les propos de monsieur michael
npd qui sont très défini que j'ai hâte
de voir si vous me permettez rapidement
c'est à partir de quel moment
stephen harper et les siens vont se dire
merde de l'ennemi le plus dangereux
c'est pas justin trudeau c'est à malmö
caf taton devrait tourner dokdo vers
thomas mulcair est ce qu'ils vont le
faire pour l'instant que le npd soit
fort qui prennent des votes aux libéraux
ça les arrange missiles en prend trop
ici se rapproche trop des conservateurs
peut-être qu'à ce moment là
la stratégie va changer mais c'est passé
mais actuellement le problème ne sait
trop d'où c'est que comme toutes les
publicités celles qui sont efficaces et
celle qui rejoint une certaine réalité
et il monsieur trudeau c'est vrai on ne
sait pas encore très bien ce qu'il veut
ce qu'il est il a pris la publicité très
efficace quand quelqu'un du thé est ce
que vraiment la légalisation du pote ça
correspond à un problème ou est-ce qu'on
doit vraiment envoyer des vêtements aux
séries c'est une caricature mais c'est
une caricature qui touche dans le maine
parce que c'est vrai qu'on sait pas ce
que monsieur trudeau fait publicité qui
est seulement en anglais donc on
pas sur les écrans québécois mais de
belgique semblait pas être un peu
différent parce que il ya un autre
joueur qui est le npd qui généralement a
grugé des votes qui le bloque bij et
qu'ils jugeaient qui dirigeait les votes
du npd et là ça ne semble pas vouloir se
reproduit je pense qu'un [ __ ] s'est
enraciné mieux qu'on aurait cru
monsieur - kay a pris une place je pense
dans les cimes des du québécois qui va
faire en sorte que ce n'est plus
simplement le la vague les thèmes le jeu
place le npd là pour un moment au québec
et le bloc québécois est ce que
l'arrivée de pierre karl péladeau sera
écouté change péladeau a pris dès le
départ ses distances avec le bloc on a
vu qu'il serait très injuste on est un
peu les choses mais je pense monsieur
péladeau ne veut pas s'associer trop
avec le bloc qui risque d'avoir de
connaître une élection extrêmement
difficile et s'il faut que le pq
attaches a dit mme sa fortune à sept du
bloc c'est extrêmement risqué alors il
va il va faire je sans toi est accusée
d'avoir laissé tomber le bloc mais pas
plus non je pense pas que monsieur
péladeau a intérêt à s'aligner avec le
bloc que ce qui reste du bloc parce que
le bloc est officiellement ce n'est pas
un grand parti ça ne mord pas un grand
parti malgré le fait qu ils recollent
dans les sondages et je pense que les
[ __ ] certainement on voit que la vague
orange persiste persistant le reste du
pays aussi et ce n'est pas ses 10 passes
et monsieur layton
tu as raison c'est quelque chose qui a
maintenant monsieur mulcair a pris la
relève de sa s mais est ce que ça peut
demeurer pour cinq mois c'est long cinq
mois alors on va voir s'ils ont un cinq
mois daniel même pendant les jeux
j'attends très peu de bémol sur sur le
bloc québécois je voudrais pas que le
bois quoi faire élire 50 députés non
sauf que si le bloc réussi à se
maintenir entre 15 et 20% ils vont jouer
les trouble-fête dans plusieurs
circonscriptions
ça peut favoriser à les libéraux ça peut
favoriser le npd et de la grande région
québec ça veut mais favoriser des
conservateurs le bloc peut aussi faire
élire des députés peut-être pas une
tonne mais il peut en faire et liam est
là où je rejoins michel et à chasser que
les déboires du mouvement souverainiste
ils ont commencé avec la défaite
magistrale de gilles duceppe du bloc
québécois il ya quatre ans
ça s'est poursuivi avec la défaite de
pauline marois et le mauvais résultat
dans les élections complémentaires alors
que monsieur péladeau veille s'associer
clairement avec le bloc québécois moi
aussi ça m'étonnerait énormément donc
cette rumeur que les élections
pourraient être déclenchées un peu plus
tôt tasha vous qu'est ce que vous en
pensez sous possibilité vraiment du mois
d'août c'est une possibilité pour une
raison qu'on a mentionné plus tôt c'est
à dire pour les raisons financières
parce que les conservateurs quand on
comptabilise combien ils ont récolté
depuis 2012
c'est 70 millions de dollars libéraux
c'est 40 l'indicé 30
si on étend la période électorale chaque
semaine ça équivaut à environ 6 5
millions de dollars de dépenses alors ce
que les parties ce que les conservateurs
aimerait bien c'est que les autres
dépenses beaucoup maintenant vie de leur
caisse parce qu'ils ont tant publicité à
faire l'éloge la longue période
électorale ses concepteurs
et n'oublions moins que young daniel il
ya surprise milliards d'allocations
familiales qui vont arriver par des
postes de l'allier la fia il si une
campagne électorale et a déclenché dans
la foulée de ça ça serait déjà messages
sympathiques de la part des
conservateurs en tout cas soyez pas
permis au club mais quand même ça aurait
quelques implications pour nous qui
sommes ici ce soir alors merci beaucoup
à vous trois pouvoirs